محطه التي تثير قلق العالم اجمع محطه
سبورجي النوويه التي اصبحت تحت سيطره
الروس
هذه هي المباني التي توجد فيها المفاعلات
النوويه سته
يقودون الى المكان نحن صحفيون الغربيون
الاوائل الذين تمكنوا من الدخول منذ شهور
موقع تتبادل مسكوه الاتهامات بقسفه
كما حدث في تشرين الثاني الماضي
حيث سقطت عشرات القضاء في المنطقه المحيطه
بالمحطه ولا تزال اثار القصف الى يومنا
هذا
كما ترون قد تم تلحيم الاماكن المتضرره كل
هذا الجزء كانت به ثقوب وكان الماء يتسرب
منها
كانت مقيده فلا يحق لنا تحدث مع عمال
المحطه او الدخول الى المباني
في المقابل تنفي اوكرانيا بشده قصفها
للمحطه وتتهم روسيا باستعمالها كمخزن
للاسلحه الثقيله خلال زيارتنا شاهدنا
مركبات عسكريه روسيه
لكن يجب ان نحمي هذه المحطه لقد كانت تحت
المراقبه ايام السلم فكيف لا تراقب اليوم
وبشده ونحن في حرب
اذا ما هو الحل بالنسبه لهذه المحطه
القريبه من جبهه القتل الى الان لا تزال
المفاوضات جاريه مع وكاله الطاقه الذريه
لانشاء منطقه حمايه الامن والسلامه
النوويه